I think that the United States should
use the power it has at its disposal to
first of all,
protect itself and protect its
interests,
but then to the extent that we can try
to create a more stable and more orderly
world.
The problem is there's not very much we
can do on that front in what separates
me from,
you know,
many other people who work in the field
of American foreign policy is I think
there are real limits to our capacity to
shape other societies that is not our
business or within our capacity to
dictate how other societies are going to
run.
I think that's their job and we're.
If we try to do it,
we're going to screw it up far more
often than we're going to succeed.